avant de commencer gk une petite
confidence à faire parce que ça va quand
même un petit peu stressée je vais pas
vous mentir
il ya un an j'étais dans cette salle en
tout cas passer la main à une autre mais
pour le premier tedx de l'école
polytechnique il ya votre place dans
public et je me suis dit voilà
j'aimerais pas être à la place des
speakers ce que ça a l'air d'être
vraiment stressant et me voilà
aujourd'hui à parler un petit peu de de
développement durable donc je suis
étudiant en génie mécanique à l'utc et
en design industriel
une question que je me pose beaucoup en
ce moment c'est qu'est ce qu'un bon
produit je sais pas si vous êtes déjà
posé cette question qu'est-ce qu'a mon
produit enfin bon produit ça produit
utile un produit fonctionnel elle sera
produit dure à l'ouest un produit
rentable
je me suis posé cette question en
observant les produits que j'utilise le
quotidien à commencer par mon téléphone
je sais des roses un iphone rose ne me
jugez pas simple donc j'ai un problème
avec mon téléphone au niveau du
connecteur impossible de le recharger un
faux contact au niveau de la charge
j'ai donc décidé de remplacer moi même
le composant défectueux première
surprise est là c'est pas possible c'est
le collecteur est liée à d'autres
composantes du téléphone à savoir la
prise jack
l'antenne et de micros donc pour
remplacer un seul de ces composants il
faut remplacer le dock tout entier
deuxième surprise pour retirer le dock
il faut au préalable
retirer la batterie qui est maintenant
est collé à la coque est pour l'a
décollé il faut utiliser à ses cheveux
c'est pas facile certes pas passer tout
ça pour vous dire que l'iphone n'a pas
été conçu pour durer
il me semble qu'on peut dire la même
chose de beaucoup d'autres produits de
la vie quotidienne comme la machine à la
ville par exemple je sais pas si vous
avez déjà réussi à essayer en tout cas à
réparer une machine à laver et c'était
très déprimant
je vous dire qu'en tant qu'élève mal
géré les ingénieurs mécaniques mon ego
en a pris un coup
je suis rendu compte que j'étais donc
pas capable de réparer une machine à
laver sa machine à laver
il me semble que c'est aussi pareil de
l'imprimante et de beaucoup d'autres
produits de la vie quotidienne
ça s'appelle l'obsolescence programmée
et ça pose de gros problèmes
premier constat
avant de qu'il arrive entre nos mains ce
produit-là fallu lui il a fallu produire
un ça commence à consommer des matières
premières il a fallu transformer et tout
ce processus en fait ça ne consomme
beaucoup d'énergie et ça rejette des
déchets je rappelle que 80% de l'énergie
qu'on utilise aujourd'hui issus de haute
lisse de ressources fossiles pour nous
de ressources fossiles
80 % de ressources fossiles et on vit
sûrement limité petit problème quelque
part or il est très facile pour nous
utilisateurs de comprendre les deux
dernières phases d'utilisation puisque
c'est là qu'on va utiliser le produit
c'est là que qui va pousser mais
l'énergie qu'on lui fournit par exemple
mais c'est là qu'on va faire l'effort ou
non de le jeter parce qu'il est plus
difficile de réfléchir à l'impact que le
produit avant son utilisation
et c'est là qu'il ya beaucoup de
problèmes seront constat nous sommes de
plus en plus entouré d'objets notamment
aux objets connectés à l'heure du
numérique
on parle de l'internet des objets et je
pense qu'on peut en tant que
consommateur légitimement se poser de la
question de en avons-nous vraiment
besoin
alors nous vend des produits
intelligents mais est ce que m un
capteur dont une bouteille d'eau suffit
à la rendre plus intelligente je ne
pense pas en tout cas posons la question
qu'est ce que vous trouviez troisième
constat nous sommes en pleine explosion
démographique plus en plus de personnes
sortent de la pro b t on peut que s'en
réjouir pour eux mais le défi
environnemental est de taille d'ici la
fin de la décennie
il était prévu pour cinq milliards sur
terre est pour l'instant à l'heure
actuelle la les 2 milliards les plus
riches c'est à dire nos la chance on
parlait tout à l'heure dans les
conférences précédentes dont on consomme
80% des ressources la planète la fin du
siècle qu'on sera petit pourcent
circulent nous les deux milliards une
somme actuellement les plus riches
on sera 10% la population à la fin du
siècle nous y pensons qu'ils consomment
80% des ressources
je pense pas que ce soit possible en
tout cas il ya un gros problème
j'ai maintenant parler des initiatives
qui me semble outrés des produits qui me
semble meilleure pour l'environnement
comme lampe ou l' économie d'énergie or
moi ça me dérange pas du tout un d'avoir
une ampoule économique d'un âge et
d'énergie chez moi
par contre elle mais s'invite à
s'allumer pour produire une lumière un
peu plate forme c'est donc ça prix à
payer du développement durable moi ça me
dérange pas d'aller faire mes courses
avec un sac réutilisable mais j'oubliais
à chaque fois j'ai pu acheter un sac en
plastique
ça me dérange pas d'acheter bio mais ça
coûte plus cher ça me dérange pas de
prendre le vélib à la place de ma
voiture mais je transpire ça ne dérange
pas de faire l'effort d'éteindre la
lumière en quittant une pièce est encore
faut-il que je fasse l'effort et à la
lumière redouane assez mon collègue a
été rejetée ça parce que je le soupçonne
de savoir qu'il existe un bouton pour
allumer la lumière n'est pas savoir
qu'il existe un second bouton pour
éteindre la lumière
j'ai un petit alice pour toi il situe
exactement au même endroit c'est pas la
mater adducteurs
tout ça pour dire qu'il me semble que
les produits meilleurs pour
l'utilisateur sont souvent le résultat
d'un compromis et qu'on attend
l'utilisateur qu'il fasse un effort qui
met un peu du sien
sauf que l'utilisateur l'environnement
ça passe après les problèmes de la vie
de tous les jours
ne peut-on pas lier un produit meilleur
pour l'utilisateur est intrinsèquement
meilleure pour l'environnement a produit
qui dès sa conception a été pensé pour
réduire son impact sur l'environnement
et sans que l'utilisateur au courant
sans qu'elle ait besoin de faire des
efforts supplémentaires
je pense que c'est ça le vrai pari
aujourd'hui s'est créé des produits à la
fois meilleur pour l'utilisateur
et bien pour l'environnement maintenant
on va parler des solutions je pense
qu'il ya un regroupement les produits
qu'on a parce que j'ai mentionné au
début comme mon téléphone je pense à des
alternatives pardon comme le fan de boxe
ça téléphone modulaire je sais pas si
vous en avez déjà entendu parler des cas
proposant est en panne il suffit de il
suffit de remplacer on peut ce téléphone
est ultra modulaire et rats
personnalisable sap le rêve du marketing
one to one pour la machine à laver je
pense au projet l'increvable six
machines à laver elle aussi conçue pour
durer 50 ans très facile à entretenir et
pour l'imprimante je pense à wilfrid
l'imprimante et économie le projeta
économies de papier et ça c'est un
projet sur lequel je travaille depuis
maintenant depuis maintenant un an
en fait je suis parti du constat très
simple que j'imprimais beaucoup qu'on a
un prix mais tous beaucoup il faut 10
litres d'eau pour créer une seule
feuille a4 et pourtant quinze mille
milliard de feuilles sort de nos
imprimantes chaque année je me suis posé
une question avons nous toujours besoin
d'imprimer sur la totalité d'une feuille
a4
j'ai donc imaginé une imprimante qui
serait chargée avec un rouleau découpé
au juste nécessaire
par exemple si je vais acheter un billet
de billets pour un point un festival au
hasard on a d'un côté à gauche avec une
impression avec une imprimante
traditionnel donc une feuille a4
vous voyez qu'une bonne partie il vaut
deux parties n est pas utilisé qu'avec
mon imprimante ces automates ces motos
c'est automatique l'utilisateur n'a pas
besoin de faire d'effort en plus c'est
induits dans l'utilisation du produit
j'ai donc présenté ce projet au concours
james dyson award concours de design
international il a terminé à finalistes
de la sélection française et j'ai eu
l'occasion de discuter avec de nombreux
interlocuteurs différents très différent
et beaucoup saluent la bonne idée mais
je retiens particulièrement les
personnes qui ont réussi à remettre en
cause la légitimité d'un tel projet mais
question qu'on m'a posée c'est avons
nous toujours besoin d'imprimer
aujourd'hui c'est une bonne question
moi je pense que oui pour la simple et
bonne raison que notre génération on a
appris avec le papier ces supports de
mémoire c'est le support de notre
apprentissage
on peut toucher on peut sentir une
valeur affective forte valeur juridique
aux siens peut-être que les générations
futures seront plus aptes à quitter le
papier
encore faut-il trouver une alternative
durable en papier je peux pas je ne sais
pas si on peut dire aujourd'hui que le
numérique est une alternative durable le
stockage numérique le donner un coût
énergétique très fort donc ça ça qui
sert ce projet s'accompagne et une
transition éventuelle vers le zéro
papier il ya une seconde question qui
m'a été posée qui m'a beaucoup marqué
c'est alors très bien on s'était posé à
skis des mois s'était posée je remet
dans le contexte c'est un concours
organisé par les échos le magazine et
dans le jury avait un entrepreneur qui
me poser une question il m'a dit bon
très bien tu veux créer une imprimante
durable donc que l'utilisateur n'est pas
censé pouvoir remplacer régulièrement en
plus de ça tu peux limiter le
consommable le papier et encre qui
pourtant est la principale source de
bénéfices des entreprises la question
est très simple comment veux tu faire du
profit ça que c'est pas facile comme ça
c'est pas facile si on suit ce bon vieux
schémas d'économie et linear basé sur
une économie de croissance était de
consommation toujours produire plus
consommer plus jetez plus sauf que ce
schéma il a montré ses limites
non c'est simple le sujet aussi de du
tedx de ce soir les a marché pendant un
temps en temps il faut trouver des
alternatives et heureusement des
alternatives
il en existe comme l'économie circulaire
marque buckley on a parlé on a parlé
tout à l'heure vous compris c'est là
donc le déchet une industrie devient le
maître la première d'une autre industrie
ou d'une nouvelle industrie alors j'ai
un petit round est mort ça arrive c'est
pas très grave
m'en fous m'en voudrez pas sur mon
premier des ducs alors ça c'est la fin
c'est d'accès ma dernière slide ça donne
déjà un indice
je sais
alors
non
je sais aussi qu'il nous reste un près
d'une minute donc ça me laisse le tour
de me sortir de sortir une fiche ça vous
dérangera pas j'espère vous voudrez pas
soyez indulgents alors l'économie
circulaire
c'est vrai il suffit juste d'amour
s'appelle le recyclage le recyclage
c'est très très bien voilà c'est super
le recyclage c'est super c'est qu'un
pansement
c'est un pansement sur le problème
pensons aux changements en aval de
changer pour seulement comme on le fait
actuellement où je vais revenir à la
question qui m'a été posée au début
la question qu'on m'a posée c'est
comment faire d'un produit durable
produits rentables
or c'est possible au sein d'une économie
circulaire
je prends l'exemple de xerox claire
zerok c'est aujourd'hui devant plus
d'imprimantes xerox souvent l'impression
la faille à l'unité c'est à dire co2 et
rocks reste propriétaire de ces
imprimantes gc chez ses clients est
chargé d'en assurer sa maintenance
c'est à dire que xerox a tout intérêt à
créer les imprimantes les plus durs
impossible c'est leur seul moyen
d'ailleurs de se faire de faire du
bénéfice
et c'est ce qu'ils font en 90 % des
composants les imprimantes xerox sont
utilisables
on peut garder enfin les imprimantes
xerox sont conçus pour endurer mais ça
fonctionne ça marche ce portrait bien
c'est pareil aussi pour michelin par
exemple michelin ne vend plus ne vont
plus les pneus mais le service
pneumatiques alors oui nous
consommateurs on doit faire des efforts
c'est vrai mais je pense qu'il est de la
responsabilité de l'ingénieur designer
en général dd ce changement en fait vous
allez tout simplement offrir un produit
à ford ans c'est-à-dire instinctif un
produit proposé qu'on a envie d'acheter
un produit qui du fait de son
utilisation de même un impact en tout
cas au moins est moins important que les
autres produits sans viande
alors il n'y a jamais été aussi facile
de créer aujourd'hui avec les fab lab
avec l'open source le numérique
financement participatif nous encourage
à cru c'est très bien écrit pourquoi
très pour créer la création tant que
finalité créé pour le profit je veux
devenir riches ont créé au service d'un
monde durable
aujourd'hui le développement durable il
semble que c'est plutôt un compromis
moi je pense que c'est pas compromis ni
une bonne idée en tout cas ce que c'est
pas qu'une bonne idée je pense que le
développement durable aujourd'hui est
une nécessité
créons des produits meilleurs pros tilly
thater est meilleure pour
l'environnement crayon oui au service
d'un monde durable
merci